- Okay, Hadi, so we are
working in this field of AI
for a couple of years now,
but it seems that, you know,
AI is always exciting, but it
became even more so recently.
So what are some of the
things that really get you,
like interested and even
more and more excited
about the future right now.
- Yeah, no, the past like
year, couple of years,
have been very, very
exciting in this field.
Like we are observing really,
really powerful AI models,
whether with, you know, ChatGPT
and large language models recently,
and even like slightly before that
with like these amazing diffusion models
that allow us to like,
amazing generative AI models
very easily generate super,
highly realistic images
with a very, very, you know, easy way
with just like textual prompting.
You can now any one of us, very easily
interact with these models
and generate amazing images.
You want the image of a dog, you know,
in New York on a skateboard
that will give you an amazing,
you know, image, super realistic.
And you can imagine how,
what amazing stuff you can do with this.
Basically translating our imagination
and everything that we
think of into actual images
and maybe in the future videos as well.
It's really awesome.
Like, this is very, very exciting for me.
- So just walk me through.
So essentially like imagine I am an artist
or I'm not an artist, I
just want to, I have a hobby
or I just want to have a nice illustration
for my Christmas card.
I just type in what I want
and one of these models
just give this to me.
- Yeah, exactly.
Like previously, like you have to like
maybe learn Photoshop, like
to create like an amazing,
you know, nice, like a
very nice photo or like,
you want to, like, you should hire someone
to like create like a nice
card for you for Christmas,
for example or like any
other celebration like,
now you just, like, whatever in your mind,
you just talk to the computer,
literally talk to these AI models,
tell them I want the image
of a blah and a blah.
Like you can create
wherever you want literally
with very, very ease.
Like, everyone can do that.
This is the amazing thing.
Like, it's super easy and super good.
Like, it's amazing how
good it is right now.
- So you mentioned Photoshop,
so it's not only about like
creation something completely new,
but you can also modify existing photos.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely,
certainly like these
models are not only about,
yeah, generating things from
scratch and your imagination.
You can actually bring photos,
like the photo of you and your wife,
you would like to go
to Hawaii for example,
but you can't afford that, for example,
you can just like Photoshop that
in a very easy way right now.
Like you don't have to know
anything about Photoshop.
You can create amazing photos.
You can edit your photos with your wife
or with your friends in a
very super realistic way.
And very easily you just specify,
oh, this is the photo of me and my wife.
I want like to change the
background to be, you know,
in Maui or Hawaii or anywhere,
like anywhere in Hawaii,
for example, anywhere in the world.
You will do it immediately,
like in one second,
literally it's amazing.
- Okay, so that's super exciting.
I'm sure my wife will be
excited about this as well.
She will definitely prefer that
to actually going to Hawaii.
So, but like now that starts
to get me a bit worried, right?
So essentially like we are not used
as a society to this kind of, you know,
ease of creation of like
very realistic images
or modification of images
that anyone can do.
So aren't you worried
about it a little bit?
- Yeah, it's certainly an amazing,
but also like, certainly like very risky
and like it definitely worries me,
like, although we can like
do amazing stuff with it,
we can also like do amazingly
good bad stuff with it.
Like we can easily like imagine
now people using these tools
to like create, you know, fake images,
spreading them online,
spreading misinformation.
They might create, you know,
a fake image of some explosion somewhere,
which will cause like, you know,
stock markets to react to this,
you know, fake image or video.
It'll cause like maybe
tension between countries
and even on a more mundane level,
like people might be able
to like can right now
manipulate other people like their friends
or their like other
people's images in a bad way
and maybe like blackmail them
if they're actually bad people
to give them money, otherwise
they will spread these,
you know, maliciously
modified or edited images.
All of us have images
online right now, right?
So like everyone literally,
if there's a malicious
actor without any experience
with like Photoshop or anything,
they can bring these images,
download them from wherever they are,
use these AI models to edit
these images maliciously,
make us look very bad,
make us do something that's
like we don't want to do
and then blackmail us to actually,
you know, give them money,
otherwise they will spread,
so it's pretty risky,
like, there's so many
things that can go wrong
with this technology basically.
- Okay, so that's a lot.
And actually quite scary,
so let me unpack this.
So first of all, you mentioned kind of,
you know, kind of coming
up with some fake images,
some explosions, actually
recently this happened.
- [Hadi] Yeah.
- There was an explosion,
well purported explosion at Pentagon
that kind of went on
Twitter and now it's X.
- [Hadi] Exactly.
- And essentially this caused some ripples
before people realize
this is a fake image,
but like what you're saying is
actually even more malicious
and even more inside you.
So you are saying, okay,
now if I want to take any
photo of let's say you online,
you know, you have it on
Instagram, on Twitter,
on your webpage.
- Yeah.
- And then I can use it using
this AI advances to create,
like to put you in some
compromising situation.
And I can say, look, Hadi,
if you don't pay me
this much of a Bitcoin,
I will just spread it around.
And yes, you know, this
will be a fake photo,
but you know, just the damage of you
having to explain it to everyone and so on
just might be not worth.
And you say, okay, I will pay you.
And of course it might not
work if actually, you know,
if I'm your friend because
then you know who I am
and there will be a lot of social costs.
But I guess you can
imagine that like scammers,
like professional scammers
can just do it online,
like can do this at scale because
you essentially don't need
human in the loop in that.
And essentially that's
something that happens.
- Yeah, I think like this,
like doing it at scale
is in particular very dangerous.
Like before, like if
there's a malicious actor,
they have to like be very
professional, you know,
at Photoshop, et cetera.
And like they have to do it
like one image at a time,
or they have have to recruit
many people to do it.
Now, a person, a single person,
single malicious actor can do it at scale
that can modify the
images or edit maliciously
the images of thousands
of people immediately.
This is very dangerous.
Like it's ease of use,
it's scalable nature
is very, very, it makes
it actually in particular,
you know, dangerous in
a much more serious way
than like how Photoshop
is dangerous, for example.
- Yes, so I completely
agree with that actually.
Like I was testifying in Senate
and one of the other witnesses
there was actually a woman
who was essentially a, you
know, she was a victim of a scam
based on essentially
like someone called her
and played to her, the clip
of her daughter saying,
okay, I got kidnapped.
And then they kind of, these people say,
okay, you need to give us ransom,
otherwise something will
happen to your daughter.
Of course, as you can imagine,
this was an extremely
traumatic experience except,
and that's the good part,
is that it turned out that
her daughter is totally fine
and this clip of her
daughter kind of saying
that I was kidnapped was
actually fake using AI.
So this is kind of a bit
more individualized effort,
but yes, above the kind of things
that we used to trust implicitly,
now we need to learn not to trust.
And again, this scale of it,
that's something that makes me
worried quite a bit as well.
So future is grim, is there
anything we can do about it?
- It's a very, very serious
problem and that's why we like,
we have to do something about it.
And that's what, you know,
why we are trying to
do something about it.
And this is exactly what we
try to do in our, you know,
recent project, recent research paper,
you know, PhotoGuard.
We're trying to attempt to
like solve this problem.
We're trying to see if there's anything
that we can do there.
So in this project, what we tried to do,
or the idea that we
wanted like to go after
is like is there a way
where we can actually prevent
this from happening by,
you know, maybe modifying the image,
our images that we upload online
in a way such that they, you know,
hinder any attempts of
manipulating them by these models.
So this is like the idea that
like we were thinking of like,
oh, is there anything we can do there?
And indeed we tried and
we actually have something
that seems to be working and
it's a prototype of course,
but like, it's just like
shows that we have stuff
that we can do there.
We are able to like, you know,
protect our images in a specific way.
- Yeah, so let me kind of
unpack it a little bit.
So first of all, you know,
before we actually explain in more detail
what this is doing,
actually there's a nice story about this.
- Yeah.
- So can you kind of tell us
how actually this project came about?
Because I think that's pretty cool.
- Yeah, totally, totally.
So like, you know, I was watching,
like I'm a big fan of Trevor Noah.
I was watching the Daily Show,
you know, before it stopped,
back like in December.
And there was this like, you know,
episode with like Trevor Noah
interviewing Mira Murati,
the CTO of OpenAI.
And they were discussing,
basically it was like the time
where DALL-E too came out.
And it's like an amazing, you know,
very powerful AI model
for like generating,
you know, images and also like edit.
It has like the capability
of editing images.
It's one of these like very
powerful generative AI models.
So they were discussing
this and Trevor asked Mira,
it was like, he was like
exactly discussing this, like,
oh, this is amazing,
but this is super scary.
Like he was literally
mentioning all of these risks
that we were talking about right now.
And he was like, oh, is
there anything we can do?
And Mira responded, of course,
like, we have to do things
and you know, you know,
things have to happen
and like they're trying
to do things, et cetera.
But like what we were talking
about maybe with watermarking
and other things, but then I was like,
oh yeah, I think I know one
way that might be able to like,
you know, fix this problem.
And we, given that like we
have worked a lot on like,
you know, adversarial examples,
I got like this idea of like,
why don't we use these things?
And I can explain later as
well what these things are.
Why don't we use this technology
to actually protect our images?
Like it might be actually
very easy to do that.
So that's where the idea came from.
I was literally having dinner with my wife
and literally watching this episode
and we just came up with this idea.
- Okay, so let's back up a little bit.
So what we're trying to do in PhotoGuard
is kind of develop this procedure
for kind of immunizing your photos
that you upload online from, you know,
them being edited using this a AI models.
Okay, so that's the idea.
Somehow we would like to make sure
there's some like protective coating
that doesn't really change the image to us
and if humans looking at it,
but somehow this AI models
have really hard time
or it's impossible for them
to actually realistically
change the image.
So that's the goal.
So now you mentioned this thing
called adversarial examples.
So can you give us a bit of a hint
of what adversarial examples are
and how they kind of fit the picture here?
- Yeah, totally.
So adversarial examples is
like an interesting phenomenon
in machine learning.
It's these small perturbations
which we can add to images,
which we feed to our
machine learning models,
which will disrupt,
totally disrupt the machine
learning model behavior.
So for example, imagine you
have the image of a dog, okay?
And imagine there is a classifier,
a machine learning model
that recognizes this dog with
very, very high accuracy.
It's amazing at recognizing this dog.
An adversary example is
basically a small modification
to this image of a dog,
which keeps it for us humans
as the image of a dog.
So for us humans, we don't
see anything that changed.
It's small changes in the pixels
such that it actually leads to an image
which will be recognized by
this machine learning model
as totally different thing.
It'll think that this image of a dog,
which for us humans looks
like a dog is actually a cat.
So the model will just
like totally misunderstand
what the image is.
- So you're saying, okay,
so a real example is essentially this way
in which you can take an existing image
and change it in a way that's
imperceptible to humans
by modifying the pixels a little bit.
So as the any machine learning model
that kind of works with
this image will, you know,
will kind of think something different.
You can essentially like steer
the behavior of this model
or disrupt the behavior of
this model on this image.
Okay, how does it fit to?
- And it has been and
of course you can see
how this is like a dangerous thing.
Like it has always been observed that
adversary examples are bad things, right?
Like we have a machine learning model
and people now can actually attack it,
what we call it adversarial attack.
We can attack this model by
changing small, you know,
by doing small imperceptible changes
to the inputs of this model
and can break our model.
So it has always been to observe that
these things are bad things.
What we did in our project
in PhotoGuard is actually,
you know, repurposing these, you know,
this phenomenon to actually
make it something good.
This phenomenon adversarial
examples is very good at like
breaking machine learning models, right?
So why don't we use it
to actually break these,
you know, AI generative models
if they try to manipulate our images.
So that's where the
idea came out from like,
we know that this tool exists,
this thing actually this phenomenon sorry,
exists in machine learning.
Let's use it in the right way.
Let's use it to actually, you
know, reinforce what we want.
Let's use it to actually
protect our images.
So let's add this, you know,
small adversarial imperceptible
perturbations to our images
before uploading them online,
such that if they actually get past
by some malicious actor
to some diffusion model,
so that they edit them,
they will not work.
It'll basically these perturbations,
these small immunizations that we add,
would disrupt this AI model.
So this is the overall idea basically.
- I see, so essentially
we are kind of using
those perturbations as a
like this protective layer
because it'll essentially
like yes to us humans,
this will still be the same picture,
but any model that tries to act on it
will kind of get confused
and not work well.
- Exactly.
- Great, so here we have
this idea, this solution.
So is it ready to go?
Like can we just start using it right now?
- So what we did is basically a prototype.
As a research lab, you know,
we do prototypes and
demonstrate that this thing
is actually, you know, feasible,
it actually disrupts, you
know, existing models.
And we actually got it to work.
We actually got it to
like disrupt, you know,
a few open source models, you
know, stable diffusion models.
But for this to actually
make be a practical solution,
there definitely is
like a couple of things
that we need to take into account.
And before of course, it's a
tool that everyone can use.
So the first thing is
that it's very important
to actually make these
immunizations robust to, you know,
tampering attempts by malicious actors.
If I immunize my image and put it online,
someone might actually
attempt to remove this,
reverse engineer this immunization
by doing some tricks, you
know, like cropping the image,
maybe like adding something to it,
maybe filtering it, maybe like,
you know, taking a screenshot of it.
So we have to build these,
you know immunizations
to be robust to such phenomenons.
So this is the first
thing that has to happen.
And the second thing is that
once we immunize our images
and put them online,
we have to guarantee in some way
that they will work for
future generation models.
Like they might actually
work for current models,
but we have to have some
way to make sure that
if there's a new model that
will come in the future,
these immunizations will work for it.
So we have to like make
them future proof basically,
or forward compatible with future models.
And for this to happen, it's
very hard to do this thing
as a user personally,
it has to come from the actual
developers of these models,
because they are the ones who know
what the future models will look like.
They can guarantee that
these immunizations
will actually also like immunize images
against future models
that they will build.
So these are like two of the core things
that in my opinion has to happen
before this is a practical tool.
- Okay, so let's go the one by one.
So for this question of like
being resistant to tampering
after the images is put online,
like what can we do?
Like how would you go about, you know,
like making them resistant
to this tampering?
- Yeah, it seems like a tough problem,
but luckily we have a
huge amount of literature
on exactly solving this problem,
but like in a different context.
So there's like few years of work
on exactly making adversarial examples,
robust to such tampering effects.
So generating robust
adversarial perturbations,
we can utilize all the
research that happens there
to exactly apply it to this problem
and this will actually like work,
like it's basically the same phenomenon
in different contexts.
So we are lucky to have like
this huge amount of work
that previously was like,
oh, to make that tax robust,
but now it translates naturally
to making the defenses robust basically.
- I see, so that's very like, interesting.
So people were working hard
to make these attacks even more nasty.
- [Hadi] Exactly.
- But we can use them
to make our immunization
to be much more nasty
in a sense that like,
you know, essentially much,
much harder to a counteract.
- Exactly.
- That's great.
So now let's talk about this other issue.
So we're saying, okay, you know,
one thing that's important to
understand about PhotoGuard
is that it's kind of,
it has to know what kind
of models we are trying to,
you know, we are trying
to protect the, you know,
like the image against,
and of course we might do it
for all the existing models,
but you know there will be new models
developed in the future
and there's no guarantee that
whatever we do at this point
will also work against them.
But what you're saying, saying oh,
that sounds like a hopeless proposition
and saying, okay, maybe
now our image is protected,
but in two years it might
not, what you're saying,
okay, so one way to approach
this question saying,
oh, actually any legitimate
developer of this model,
probably, you know, is on board
with having this kind of
protections work because,
you know, that's definitely
not against the business,
it actually helps them, you know,
counteract some of the problems there.
So you could actually imagine
there would be some cooperation of them
when they say to actually make sure
when they design the model
that the new models in
released in the future
are also like, you know,
essentially this is funny
that they make sure they are susceptible
to these perturbations,
which means that this kind of protections
will continue to work.
- Exactly, exactly.
Like, it's funny here that like now
we have the incentive to make our models
more susceptible to these, you know,
attacks or adversarial perturbations,
which before we didn't want
because we want to make our
models robust to these things.
But like in this particular,
you know, scenario or situation,
these companies have the
incentive to make their models,
you know, like, breakable
by these immunizations.
Like they have the incentive to do that
because if people want to use
these models in a good way
to manipulate these image in a good way,
they must be able to,
but if they want to protect their images,
they also have to be able to do that.
And this is like how these companies
can actually like get in there
and like provide these,
you know, APIs for example,
to immunize our images against
their models basically.
- Okay, so I guess the
future would be that maybe
it's all happening automatically,
each time you upload your
image from your iPhone,
it just happens in the background
and as usual don't have
to think about that.
So that's great.
That's a great vision
that we might go towards,
but kind of, I just wanted to
go back to one of the concepts
that you mentioned in the passing recently
because it's kind of
complementary is the watermarking.
So what is watermarking
and in what way it can help
or not help the scenarios
and kind of how does it differ
from the type of functionality
that PhotoGuard wants to provide?
- Yeah, very good question.
So like watermarking,
we're hearing about
watermarking everywhere
in the context of, you
know, language models.
We wanna want watermark, you know,
like the output of these models
so that we can track them.
We are hearing about it
also like in the context
of these diffusion models.
So watermarking basically is a way
where you actually add some, you know,
like something to the image
that's generated by these models
so that you can detect that
it's actually a fake image,
not an actual or real image.
And it definitely is a legit way
to like go towards, you know,
like keeping track of like
what images we are generating
because it's important that
the images that we generate
or other people generate are tracked,
whether it's they're fake or
not fake for many reasons,
like for, you know, like
misinformation tracking,
for many, many different reasons.
And this is a very, very good,
you know, direction of course,
it differs from PhotoGuard
in the fact that like,
it's comes like as in, you
know, a post, you know,
like it's not a preventive solution
of the edit from happening
at the first time.
It's like a post hoc maybe
like that's what you call it.
Like it's a post hoc solution,
like it comes afterwards.
We generate a fake image and
now we can track it if it's,
we can detect it if it's fake or not.
The problem that might happen,
purely detecting fake images
can sometimes be not enough.
For example, if there is the image
of some explosion somewhere,
even before it's flagged,
whether it's like,
you know, fake or not, the
effect might happen already.
Like stock markets might react
like before even people double check
or you know, fact check whether
it's, you know, fake or not.
Imagine there's like an
edited photo of a child
in some school, which makes this child
look embarrassed, for example.
The effect has happened
already before, you know,
even after, you know, the
school announces that,
oh, it turns out this is a fake photo.
So there's like preventing
these edits from happening
at the first place was, you know,
one of our main goals
as well in this tool.
It's like, yeah, it's a preventive measure
compared to like, you know,
detective measure basically.
And both of them are
complimentary, of course.
Like if something is not prevented,
hopefully we can detect it basically.
- Sounds great, so essentially
you are saying that like,
it's like actually you could use both,
like they're complimentary.
The problem with watermarking
is that essentially yes,
you can check that this photo is fake,
assuming you can do the
watermarking robustly enough.
- [Hadi] Yeah.
- But like the photo is already there.
- Yes.
- Where we are trying to
not let the photo happen to begin with.
- Exactly.
- Okay, so this is kind
of all very interesting
and we are very kind of happy
that we can provide this ideas
into the space, but like, you know,
as you look at the
landscape moving forward,
like, you know, are you
optimistic at where we are going?
Are you worried about where we are going?
What is your feeling here?
- AI as a field is moving very, very fast.
And like a year ago or two years ago,
we didn't imagine that like the progress
will happen this fast,
whether it was with these
amazing generative models
or even with like ChatGPT and like,
things are moving very, very fast.
So it's hard to predict
what's coming next,
but even without anything new coming next,
we have already like very serious risks
that accompany our AI tools right now.
So I think a major challenge
is actually, you know,
dealing with the current technology as is,
while thinking that like
this is just improving
and improving in the future more and more.
For example, one thing
that I worry really about
is like the open source
nature of these models.
Open source is an amazing thing,
of course as a researcher,
as a PhD student, I love it.
Like, you know, I can like
play with these models,
I can have access to everything,
but we can imagine like
if these very powerful
generative models are accessible by anyone
to even train them very
quickly on like small machines
on one GPU for example,
then this problem is not solvable anymore.
Like if we reach that situation,
no one can solve this problem.
Like, that's it.
Anyone in us and on his laptop
can train these amazing generative models
in a way that they, you know,
fool whatever, you know,
immunization layers we have
and that's it, game over.
Like I don't think there is
a solution there anymore.
So this is one of the things
that is very, very risky
in my opinion, for example.
- I see, so, so just to actually like,
so that's an important point
that you make saying like
kind of implicitly in
actually both watermarking
and the you know, and
the PhotoGuard, you know,
relies on the fact that
there are developers
that are kind of like legitimate
and they are willing
to do the right thing.
- Exactly.
- Implement the watermarking,
implement PhotoGuard.
- Yeah.
- But now if everyone
can train their own model
in the basement, then you
know, that's up to them.
If they are not legitimate,
they will just do all these things.
You can have some law that
compels them to do it,
but in the end the enforcement of that
may be much, much harder.
- Much harder, yeah.
- So, okay, so it sounds like
there's a lot of exciting
stuff moving forward,
there's a lot of danger.
I think our society has to
think really, really hard
about like, you know, what's to come.
And as usual, we might
not be able to predict
all the implications what's to come.
I think, you know, the policy
has to catch up with this as well.
This is no longer just something
that only engineer can solve.
But yeah, so I guess we will see
what the next couple of years will bring.
- Yeah, very exciting.
I like, I'm super excited
about what's coming next,
like, as an AI researcher,
like this is all what I like to do.
Like, I just like to like
develop these models,
make them as powerful as possible.
Like I love doing that,
but at the same time I also like
worry about like their implications.
So I work a lot on like, you know,
we as a team work a lot like on, you know,
making them robust, making
them, you know, trustworthy,
making them, you know,
deployable in a confident way,
basically like making us like
confident when we deploy them,
figuring out like all of these questions,
it's super exciting but also
super, super challenging
because like the advancements in AI
is moving really, really fast.
- Yeah, well looking forward
to continue to work with you on just that.
- [Hadi] Yeah.
- Thank you for tuning in
to the discussion about PhotoGuard.
I hope you found it interesting.
- Yeah, we're happy that you're
listening to our discussion
and if you have any questions,
of course, reach out.
Thank you so much for listening.